I opposed it I believe it's in 1999 I
think I was the only Republican that
voted against the repeal of
glass-steagall because it had worked for
years what he did basically is separate
investment banking which is highly
leveraged banking from commercial
banking which is highly regulated when
you repeal glass-steagall you put it on
in commercial banking and you've seen a
lot of problems that come with it we
were assured then but I didn't believe
it at the time that they would not be
putting the taxpayers at risk you know
by doing this now we know better than
that now the question is can we change
that I don't know if we can ever go back
to glass-steagall as it was but but the
regulators can do a lot toward making
sure that the commercial banks don't
jeopardize themselves by their
investment banking or proprietary
trading
I don't know if we can reinstitute
glass-steagall some people have
advocated dr. Volkers advocated it
Senator McCain and others have because
once something's past is past but I
think that we if we can't do that that
we certainly could make sure through the
regulatory process that the taxpayers
are not put it in harm's way
well you asked a lot of questions there
the Fannie and Freddie they're going to
be gone it's a question and they're
already gone this far as a viable
you know private or hybrid enterprise
the question is how only be before the
private sector can pick up the roll that
they're doing and what will that role
will that be as far as the mortgage
deduction you know that's very popular
in America well with and it's probably
aided and abetted a lot of homeownership
so that's probably something that most
people wouldn't touch